appelle mit blick auf herbst und winter
wer corona listen im restaurant falsch
ausfüllt muss künftig mit geldstrafen
rechnen
schlagabtausch oder schlammschlacht
us-präsident trump und herausforderer
beiden bestreiten heute nacht ihr erstes
tv duell und warnstreik bei bussen und
bahnen die gewerkschaften fordern mehr
geld für pendler und schüler hieß es
viel geduld
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers meine damen und herren
guten abend in allen und herzlich
willkommen heute um 7 sport nachher in
dieser sendung mit katja stresow genannt
dieser dienstag markiert einen traurigen
punkt im kampf der welt gegen das virus
eine million tote hat corona
mittlerweile gefordert die johns hopkins
universität registriert die zahl der
opfer und das virus ist nicht unter
kontrolle für deutschland haben
kanzlerin und ministerpräsidenten der
länder heute über neue regeln beraten
schauen wir mal auf die ergebnisse für
regionen mit vielen neuinfektionen soll
gelten bei feiern neue obergrenzen
maximal 50 personen außerhalb der
wohnung bei privaten partys zu hause
gibt es die dringende empfehlung maximal
25 personen steigen die korona zahlen
kann das noch mal auf höchstens zehn
teilnehmer verschärft werden und
generell gilt wenn im restaurant eine
falsche adresse oder ein falscher name
in die korona liste eingetragen wird
dann drohen mindestens 50 euro bußgeld
kontrollieren sollen dass die
ordnungsbehörden die details jetzt von
weniger drei stunden hat die runde der
länderchefs mit angela merkel konferiert
vor dem treffen hatte es einige
unstimmigkeiten gegeben ob corona
maßnahmen wirklich verschärft werden
müssten danach ist klar es wird weitere
auflagen geben
wir haben viel gelernt wir sind auch
recht gut durch den sommer gekommen
aber wir wissen dass vor uns die
schwierigere zeit liegt nämlich die
herbst und wintermonate und wir sehen
einen schrittweisen anstieg zum teil in
ballungsgebieten als der deutlichen
anstieg an infizierten zahlen deshalb
soll es zum beispiel ein bußgeld in höhe
von 50 euro geben wenn besucher von
restaurants falsche kontaktdaten
hinterlassen wie zum beispiel fantasien
im zweifelsfalle also bei donald duck
ist die sache ja nicht schwierig dass
man dass es sehr unwahrscheinlich ist
aber im zweifelsfall muss man sich eben
dann auch nochmal den ausweis zeigen
lassen großes risiko sieht man bei
privaten feiern wir hier aktuell in
bielefeld mussten nach einer party
hunderte menschen getestet werden
fast 1000 sind in quarantäne schulen
wurden geschlossen
deshalb sollen feiern je nach
infektionsgeschehen in der region
kleiner ausfallen
bei der steigerung gilt der grundsatz
mehr maske weniger alkohol und kleinere
41 betonen heute alle keiner aus dieser
runde den maßnahmen wie zu beginn der
pandemie ergreifen dass das was wir alle
schon mal erlebt haben im märz ein mob
down vermieden wird dass wir die schulen
die kindergärten dass wir das
berufsleben aufrecht erhalten können und
dort handeln wo infektion dann
tatsächlich auch auftreten weiterer
appelle lüften nicht in den ferien in
risikogebiete reisen unklar aber bleibt
wie manche der angekündigten maßnahmen
kontrolliert werden sollen und wie kommt
das an bei denen die es jetzt betrifft
stimmen dazu aus berlin und dresden
wir finden das sicherlich vorsorglich in
ordnung wir haben den eindruck dass die
meisten menschen sich inzwischen etwas
gehen lassen weil die gefahr halt so
lange schon mal hielt ich finde
persönlich 50 euro zu viel strafe also
schon in öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln
finde ich 60 euro sehr hoch und ich
find's einfach nicht angemessen ich
denke dass dieser alkohol ausstand und
22 uhr nichts bringt aber spät ist ja
trotzdem geöffnet haben werden und man
sich den alkohol dann auf eine andere
weise gesagt ich sollte zentrale
vorgaben geben aber mit regionaler
auslegung und so sind wir in deutschland
gut gefahren den letzten monaten das
sollte auch weiterhin so
stimmen aus berlin und dresden waren
lass uns jetzt gehen wir live nach
berlin zu schicken talabani kontrolle
auch heute abend guten abend an dich die
kanzlerin hatte ja gestern eindringlich
gewarnt und schlimme zahlen für die
weihnachtszeit prophezeit kann sie denn
mit dem ergebnis heute zufrieden sein
also wer in den vergangenen monaten zu
gehört hat weiß dass sie sich vermutlich
auch noch an der einen oder anderen
stelle schärfere maßnahmen vorstellen
könnte es so ist es ja zum beispiel bei
der obergrenze für private feiern zu
hause bei einer empfehlung geblieben das
spiegelt aber eben auch das machbare vor
ort wieder was zum beispiel die
überwachung einer solchen obergrenze
angeht
sie wird sicherlich zufrieden sein mit
dem signal was von dem heutigen treffen
ausgeht durch diese stufen modell ist
ganz klar wenn irgendwo die zahlen
deutlich ansteigen dann wird es eben
auch schärfere maßnahmen geben diese
einigung ist sicherlich auch dadurch zu
darauf zurückzuführen dass sich hier
alle in zwei punkten einig waren zum
einen will keiner dass es noch mal das
öffentliche das unterfahren des
öffentlichen lebens in ganz deutschland
gibt und zum anderen will man wirtschaft
und bildung soweit wie möglich schonen
da gibt es übrigens offensichtlich noch
luft nach oben was die meinung der
kanzlerin angeht die hat nämlich heute
noch einmal darauf hingewiesen dass es
eine test strategie für lehrer und
schüler braucht unterm strich bleibt es
dabei die länder müssen sich kümmern es
bleibt in ihrer verantwortung wie sich
die infektionszahlen weiterentwickeln
herzlichen dank nach berlin und dann
gucken wir auf die aktuelle situation
bei den gemeldeten neuinfektionen in
deutschland im schnitt der vergangenen
sieben tage haben sich danach täglich
1870 menschen mit dem corona virus
angesteckt gestern lag der schnitt noch
bei 1770 wir bleiben beim thema in
berlin ging es heute in großer runde um
eine sehr große zahl im bundestag
erklärte und rechtfertigte
finanzminister olaf scholz die
neuverschuldung für nächstes jahr
konkret plant er mit 96,2 milliarden
euro um das land durch die korona krise
zu bekommen eine riesige summe und doch
nur knapp die hälfte
der zusätzlichen verschuldung für dieses
jahr tenor in der opposition an dem
entwurf muss noch gearbeitet werden wohl
im dezember wird der haushalt endgültig
beschlossen klaus brodbeck jetzt mit
mehr krone trägt doch diesen haushalt
gleich doppelt deutlich weniger
steuereinnahmen und rasant steigende
ausgaben 96 milliarden neuverschuldung
für olaf scholz gut investiertes geld
nichthandeln wäre viel teurer als
handeln und das ist das was wir als
motto auf den weg gebracht haben mit den
entscheidungen der regierung und mit dem
haushaltsentwurf den wegen hier zur
beratung vorlegen
wir beginnen die wahlkampf prägt die
debatte die union trägt die
neuverschuldung zwar mit fordert aber
die schnelle rückkehr zu schwarzen null
hier in diesem haus von nachhaltigkeit
von generationengerechtigkeit spricht er
muss auch von finanzieller
generationengerechtigkeit sprechen harte
kritik von der opposition die ausgaben
zu hoch die einsparungen zu gering die
finanzierung zu wenig geklärt
das ist ein kanzlerkandidaten haushalt
das war eine kanzlerkandidaten rede das
hat mit vernünftiger nachsichtiger
umsichtiger haushaltsrede und nichts
mehr zu tun die wirtschaftliche existenz
unseres landes wird auf dem altar von
annahmen und spekulationen geopfert das
grundgesetz wird missbrauch zum uhr
verlosen schulden machen
wir lehnen aus diesen gründen die korona
verschuldung ab herr minister scholz die
zentrale frage dieser debatte haben sie
nicht beantwortet die lautet nämlich wer
soll die rechnung bezahlen
auf diese frage müssen die menschen
vor der bundestagswahl eine antwort
bekommen die grünen fordern die
schuldenbremse zu modernisieren und
zukunftsinvestitionen zu erleichtern
sie haben in der krise die bazooka
ausgepackt sorgen sie dafür dass sich
nach corona die abrissbirne kommt die
ganze woche noch wird der haushalt
beraten morgen generaldebatte
es dürfte wohl krachen und jetzt ins
ausland im us wahlkampf gibt es heute
nacht ein großereignis etwa 100
millionen menschen werden mitverfolgen
wie us präsident donald trump und sein
herausforderer joe biden im ersten tv
duell aufeinander treffen
an einer uni in ohio geht es um alles
was amerika spaltet rassismus den umgang
mit corona und frisch enthüllt offenbar
ausgesprochen mickrige steuerzahlungen
des präsidenten von notorischer lügner
bis seniler kreis viele rechnen damit
dass die attacken der beiden sehr giftig
werden im at wissen verfolgt das für uns
in cleveland ohio also vor ort immer
wenn man den bisherigen wahlkampf als
messlatte nimmt dann wird das heute
nacht eine schlammschlacht auf offener
bühne absolut das kann sein im vorfeld
hat joe biden trump ja schon mit joseph
goebbels verglichen
trump wiederum hat von beiden gefordert
er soll doch bitte einen drogentest
machen bevor ihr heute abend bei der
debatte dabei ist ich glaube heute abend
wird trump vor allen dingen auch
persönliche angriffe starten auf beiden
in bezug auf die geschäfte seines sohnes
handarbeiten dass ein punkt auf den joe
biden in der regel immer sehr sehr
wütend reagiert und das macht vielen
seiner berater jetzt sorgen weil sie
befürchten verbale ausrutscher von ihm
das kann ihm sehr schaden
er ist er der favorit liegt mit rund
zehn prozentpunkten vor donald trump
landesweite hat also eigentlich am
meisten hier zu verlieren aber
andererseits hat er auch einiges zu
gewinnen in den donnerstag muss sich zum
ersten mal seit vier jahren wirklich
einen gegner auf augenhöhe stellen er
muss seine arbeit verteidigen
wir haben eine tiefe wirtschaftskrise
200.000 corona tote und wir haben
gleichzeitig auch die polarisierung im
land also es geht am ende nicht um
millionen von stimmen die man um stimmen
will heute abend sondern um ein paar
tausende in den bundesstaaten in der
sie sich ein kopf an kopf rennen liefern
das entscheidet über sieg oder
niederlage und deshalb wird das heute
eine sehr sehr harte debatte vielen dank
wir werden herrn at wissen heute nacht
wieder sehen das tv-duell trump gegen
beiden übertragen wir nämlich live im
zdf ab 2 uhr 45 und eine analyse der
kandidaten ihre stärken und ihre
schwächen finden sie bei uns in der zdf-
heute im streit um die region berg
karabach nimmt aserbaidschan jetzt auch
ziele in armenien unter beschuss beide
länder sprechen von hunderten toten auf
der jeweils anderen seite die von
armenien kontrollierte region gehört
völkerrechtlich zum islamisch geprägten
aserbaidschan in bergkarabach leben rund
145.000 einwohner viele von ihnen
christen seit 1994 gilt dort eine
waffenruhe
das ganze ist weit mehr als nur ein
lokaler konflikt armenien wird nämlich
von russland unterstützt als er bei john
hat die türkei als verbündeten christian
sam berichtet sowohl das
aserbaidschanische als auch das
armenische verteidigungsministerium
veröffentlichen immer wieder bilder die
jeweils die zerstörung feindliche
stellungen zeigen sollen
es ist auch ein krieg der informationen
in beiden ländern melden sich weiter
freiwillige für den kampf um berg
karabach so wie hier in armeniens
hauptstadt eriwan stadtroda ich bin sehr
froh dass ich früher nacht berg karabach
gehen werde
weil ich meinen brüdern helfen und sie
unterstützen möchte in anbetracht dessen
was jetzt passiert ist es besser einmal
blut zu vergießen zu gewinnen und
frieden zu schaffen
ähnlich das bild in aserbaidschans
hauptstadt baku
auch hier registrieren sich freiwillige
um in den krieg zu ziehen
auf befehl unseres präsidenten
versammeln sich hier leute gerade zu
einer teilweisen mobilisierung
das betrifft männer unter 32 jahren die
gegen ihrer berufe als geeignet
angesehen werden
berg karabach gehört völkerrechtlich zu
aserbaidschan
nach dem zusammenbruch der sowjetunion
verlor aserbaidschan die kontrolle über
das gebiet als sich die region 1991 für
unabhängig erklärte begann der krieg der
seit dem immer wieder aufflammt armenien
wird von russland unterstützt und
aserbaidschan enger verbündeter ist die
türkei armenien muss sich aus den
gebieten zurückziehen die es in
aserbaidschan besetzt hat wenn das nicht
geschieht kann das problem nicht gelöst
werden
die türkei habe mehr als 300 kämpfer aus
syrien nach berg karabach verlegt
berichten aktivisten aserbaidschan
bestreitet das und die türkei wies
berichte zurück ein türkischer kampfjet
habe ein armenisches kampfflugzeug
abgeschossen der desinformations krieg
geht weiter und die kämpfe auch jom
kippur das ist der höchste jüdische
feiertag das versöhnungsfest jom kippur
vor einem jahr das war ein furchtbarer
tag für die gemeinde in halle in sachsen
anhalt ein rechtsextremist wollte ein
massaker in der synagoge anrichten
scheiterte an der tür
außerhalb des gebäudes tötete er zwei
menschen wie feiert man da fest der
versöhnung die opfer von damals
jedenfalls rücken zusammen hagen nicolas
berichtet
gedenken minute für die opfer des
anschlags von halle vertreter der
jüdischen gemeinde besuchen den imbiss
in dem kevin s erschossen wurde
dieser besuch für inhaber ist mit tekin
ist ein zeichen der solidarität die er
seit dem anschlag erfährt das bedeutet
für mich natürlich große freude nach dem
schlagen wir sind sehr nahe gekommen und
in jüdische gemeinde die haben auch eine
spendenaktion gemacht für den neue
renovieren laden ein jahr danach braucht
es mithin noch hilfe um das geschehene
zu verarbeiten
eine gedenkwand in seinem geschäft ist
den opfern gewidmet am 19 oktober 2009
10 will ein antisemit und
rechtsextremist in der synagoge in halle
menschen töten ins gebetshaus gelangt er
nicht doch er tötete zwei menschen
verletzt auf der flucht weiter
seit juli steht der mutmaßliche täter
wegen zweifacher mord und mordversuch in
68 fällen vor gericht alle synagoge ist
an jom kippur in diesen tagen stärker
geschützt auch hier wird heute an den
anschlag erinnert aufgezeichnet für die
jüdischen gemeinden in aller welt war am
sterben
vize präsident des jüdischen
weltkongresses mahnt taten die halle
nicht als einzelfälle zu sehen
auch max privat ski vorsteher der
jüdischen gemeinde halle warnt vor
starken dem extremismus ist aber
zugleich zuversichtlich
bei allen problemen ich bin optimistisch
nur leider calvin und jana kann man
nicht zurückholen
ein jahr nach dem anschlag in halle die
wunden sind noch nicht geschlossen
wer heute auf bus und bahn angewiesen
war der erwartete oft vergeblich die
gewerkschaft verdi will bessere
arbeitsbedingungen für die beschäftigten
und rief zum warnstreik auf im
öffentlichen nahverkehr mit aktionen in
ganz deutschland
und wie hier in berlin blieben u
bahnhöfe geschlossen und busse im depot
alexander hettich beginnt sein bericht
in nürnberg die u bahn fährt nicht die
gleise sind verwaist in nürnberg rollte
nur die busse private anbieter nach
einem schmalen ersatzfahrplan nicht
leicht für die fahrer selbst ich selber
habe keine informationen und
ja seines haushalt wie man es kennt beim
streik folge kampf um plätze in vollen
bussen in corona zeiten können manche
das nicht verstehen wenn wir uns schon
wieder jetzt durch tarif streitereien
und streiks schon wieder neue probleme
schaffen bin ich das nicht so ganz in
ordnung
die beschäftigten des öffentlichen
dienstes sehen das natürlich anders
großkundgebung mit krone abstand zur
gleichen zeit in wuppertal busfahrer und
andere beschäftigt für klagen über
steigende belastungen in wuppertal tritt
der verdi chef persönlich auf herbe
druck machen ohne die bürger allzu sehr
zu verärgern es ist ja so dass ohne
streiks in dieser tarifrunde nichts
voran kommt von daher werben wir um das
verständnis und streiks im öffentlichen
dienst sind nicht unumstritten
doch den kommunen sind die forderungen
schlicht zu teuer
klamme kassen bei den kommunen wir haben
bei den kommunalen unternehmen
wirtschaftliche einbrüche und da dann
4,8 prozent für zwölf monate zu fordern
dass das schlichtweg zu viel heißt
vermutlich weitere streiks wie heute
auch in münchen in corona zeiten
reagieren viele pendler genervt das
macht es schwer für verdi druck
aufzubauen
so jetzt kommt der sport einigermaßen
unsportlich allerdings daher mit katja
zunächst zunächst 23 sportler aus acht
ländern dass die zahlen die rund um die
sogenannte operation aderlass bekannt
geworden waren sie alle waren teil eines
dopingsystems rund um den erfurter arzt
mag es der legte heute ein geständnis ab
seine einlassung war mit spannung
erwartet worden
dabei ließ der hauptangeklagte arzt
marquez seine anwälte für sich sprechen
die ihm vorgeworfenen taten des
blutdopings räumte er weitgehend ein
doping sei an der tagesordnung wenn man
erfolgreich sein wolle
unser mann dann war es wichtig heute an
zu zeigen mit welchen mussten
herzlichen ansprüchen und standort sehr
gearbeitet dass er in erster linie die
sicherheit dass verhandeln im auge hatte
und ganz klar kein geld damit verdienen
konnte kritik an diesem geständnis übt
die sportausschuss vorsitzende des
bundestags- dagmar freitag die von einem
verrat an den ethischen werten des
sports spricht der prozess ist noch bis
kurz vor weihnachten terminiert
zum tennis angelique kerber ist bei den
french open wie im vorjahr bereits in
der ersten runde ausgeschieden
besser machte es laura siegemund die us
open siegerin im doppel bezwang die
favorisierten franzosen ademovic nach 1
5-rückstand und abwehr von sieben
satzbälle noch mit 7 zu 5 und 6 zu 3 und
noch zum fußball man nutzt gern die
worte deutscher klassiker immer dann
wenn der fc bayern münchen und borussia
dortmund gegeneinander spielen morgen
ist es wieder soweit im supercup es sind
die verlierer vom wochenende die
aufeinandertreffen wer hätte das gedacht
die bayern gar mit 1 zu 4 in hoffenheim
nach zuvor 32 pflichtspielen ohne
niederlage
kratzt das am selbstbewusstsein wir
wissen dass wir nicht gut gespielt haben
aber wir haben auch enorm erfolgreiche
zeit hinter uns und deswegen kann die
mannschaft auf jeden fall enorm viel
vertrauen in ihre stärke haben und der
bvb zuletzt am boden nach dem 0 2 in
augsburg die jungen wilden ausgekontert
und jetzt gehts zu den bayern in münchen
saßen nie so gut aus morgen ist ein
neuer tag und eine neue möglichkeit das
ganze dinge umzudrehen
auf jeden fall wird es dann wieder einen
sieger geben mit denen sie in den morgen
abend live im zdf
danke katja jetzt noch so quasi die
weisheit des tages wer eingeschneit ist
sollte einen winter pulli dabei haben
das haben sie hier beherzigt hoch in den
französischen alpen 7000 schafe
überrascht vom plötzlichen
wintereinbruch das fell hilft da schon
mal enorm aber weil die tiere wegen des
schnees nicht an das gras zum futtern
kommen müssen sie jetzt schnell in
tiefere regionen und da helfen ihre
schäfer nach ein winter pulli ist halt
doch nicht alles kein schnee bei uns mal
nebelig trüb mal sonne meist mild dass
das herbstwetter in den nächsten tagen
mehr gleich von katja horneffer mehr zu
diesen nachrichten tag im heute journal
um 21.45 jetzt geht es weiter mit dem
zdf spezial rund antje pieper wir alle
hier sagen danke fürs zuschauen bis
morgen und in allen einen angenehmen
abend
[Musik]
meine damen und herren heute gab es
viele wolken im westen und auch viele
wolken im osten gebracht ein bisschen
regen mit dazwischen aber gab es einen
schmalen streifen der reichte hier
ungefähr von fehmarn bis zum bayerischen
wald wo sich die sonne zeigte dieser
schmale streifen der wird jetzt in der
nacht mehr und mehr zusammen geschoben
denn die einen wollten hier die ziehen
weiter richtung westen und die anderen
wolken im westen die ziehen weiter
richtung osten
morgen beginnt ist also erst mal mit
nebel und hochnebel der löst sich dann
aber meist bis mittags auf und dann
scheint häufig die sonne regen fällt
kaum auch in der nacht gibt's allenfalls
zwischen der nordseeküste und franken
etwas regt sonst bildet sich auch mal
nebel die luft ist recht feucht oder
kühl und die temperaturen sinken auf
werte von 13 grad am niederrhein und bis
fünf grad zum beispiel im schwarzwald
und morgen wird dass ein milder tag mit
15 grad an der donau bis zu 21 grad zum
beispiel an der eltern wenn sich nebel
und hochnebel aufgelöst haben wird es
recht sonnig nur im westen sind die
wolken etwas dichter bringen dort auch
etwas regen mit und diese verteilung
zwischen dem westen und dem osten bleibt
in den nächsten tagen ebenso also im
westen sehr stark bewölkt mit etwas
regen im osten dagegen deutlich sonniger
bei bis zu 23 grad
dennoch